I will not be satisfied until my
people's rightful lands are restored and
I am beefed their rightful principal
Chief Liz dinner's ready hold on Bruce
I'm having a pow
wow all right people we're back in
Action I'm Dave Ruben this is the ruin
report it is November 27th in the year
2023 we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube locals all the usual spots if
you haven't subscribed please do so and
if you want to join us for a chat during
the show or a postgame show that's Ruben
report. locals.com I want to note before
we uh begin today that it is Phoenix my
producer's birthday and uh we just had
birthday donuts and either I will be on
a sugar rush throughout this show or we
may just call it quits in about 7
minutes it could be a crash we will see
what happen
uh we have a big show for you today oh
and I just hope everyone had a great
Thanksgiving and maybe you were off the
machines a little bit and I hope you
were around friends and family and I
hope you ate a lot of good food and all
that stuff we ate like a ton you know I
I had mentioned last week I was at my
lowest weight last week in probably
about 15 years pretty sure I no longer
am and then I started today off with
donuts so if you pray now is the time
not only for me but for the state of the
West because there is a lot of weird
stuff happening but despite the fact
that we've been talking about some
pretty depressing stuff over the last
six or eight weeks uh there is I would
say something something turning at the
moment the rise of the Westerner might
be uh coming around let's say uh my
friend Douglas Murray is making some
sense uh Conor McGregor who you guys
know MMA fighter he is really making
some sense in England uh Tommy Rob sorry
in Ireland Tommy Robinson over in
England there are a bunch of people
fighting back obviously there was the
election in Argentina now there was an
election in the Netherlands a whole
bunch that we're going to talk about
there are these anti-socialist uh
protests in
Spain so maybe just maybe we're not
going to like completely go off the
cliff let's find out so let's do it uh
okay let's start with Douglas Murray uh
because Douglas Murray was on a podcast
with former deputy Prime Minister of
Australia John Anderson I've had John
Anderson on the show a couple times I
saw him at the ark Forum in London not
too long ago uh and they were talking
about what is happening with the West as
it relates to Illegal immigration not
just immigration but illegal immigration
letting hundreds of thousands of people
into countries that do not share the
values of those countries and what that
will do to countries over time and I
think that most of us are realizing
after the protests and the riots and the
violence and the calls for genocide and
everything else that we've seen for the
last two months that there is uh let's
say a problem with this uh so here is
Douglas Murray Hamas and their friends
are Nazis and we'll have to get rid of
them and the Israelis are doing a very
good job in the beginning of that but
everyone's going to have to join in we
cannot live with these people we can't
not because we don't want to but because
they cannot live with us so why why just
hope that those people are not en large
enough numbers and keep your fingers
crossed and put it off for another day I
think we have to start saying very
clearly if you don't like it here
go all right Douglas Murray ladies and
gentlemen Nobody Does it Better nobody
is cleaner or clearer or anything else
he's actually in Israel right now I was
texting him a day or two ago as they've
begun to release some of these prisoners
he's been there at the Children's
Hospital seeing some of the parents be
United I mean there's still probably
about 150 people that are still hostages
uh but Douglas brings up a point that I
think is kind of on everyone's mind at
the moment which is as you see these
calls for genocide on the Streets of
London that's specifically what he's
talking about there or as you see them
on the streets of Brussel or even as you
see them on the streets of New York City
or elsewhere it's like at what point
does the Western defense of free speech
come right up against a group of people
who are here some of them legally but
plenty of them illegally who are gladly
using our freedoms against us and what
do we do in Liberal societies to make
sure that over time all of the good
things about liberalism meaning
individual rights and pluralism and the
ability to live next door to somebody
who maybe doesn't share the same
religion or same view as you but but
that you come together over let's say
the idea of America how long can that
work when a whole bunch of people are
here
gladly uh and proudly screaming that
they're here to tear it all down that
seems like a problem and of course what
has uh what has started all of this I
guess well not really started it but
what has kind of put this in the in the
Forefront of everyone's mind is what
happened in Israel on October 7th so
just this morning it's now it's now
early evening in Israel right now but
Elon Musk uh is now in southern Israel
visiting some of uh the the communities
that
were decimated I don't know another word
for it uh and here's video we're going
to show you about 30 seconds this is uh
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu uh touring some of those
communities with Elon Musk last night
some of them returned home not home yet
but Israel and most of them were from
the houses over here when the terrorists
infiltrated into the kibuts
itself this is the house
of on his way back you notice several
terrorists that we right over
here it's a symbol in you have kids
inside the father around but it's
solding
shells specifically of
AAS used to
prot okay so I want to just kind of
clearly explain how I'm connecting these
two videos first Douglas and then to
this the idea now that we're all kind of
coming around to that societies Western
societies especially are going to have
to make some hard decisions relative to
the people that are in their societies
again some of them legally some of them
illegally uh comes right up against what
just happened in Israel a month or was
it now almost two months
ago what will Western societies tolerate
do we tolerate not having borders and
letting people come in and rape our
women and kill our children and burn
down whole communities and kill innocent
people and all of those things and cause
you know massive upheaval and take
hostages and everything else will we
tolerate that or will we actually be
brave enough to do the right thing not
just say we're going to do the right
thing not just say we have principles
but actually do something in the in the
face of evil now there's another layer
of this that I think is particularly
important as it relates to Elon Musk
which is that if it was not for Elon
defending free speech in this last year
since he bought Twitter SL x uh it would
be very hard to know what was going on
in the world right now because Elon has
opened it up so that when they show you
videos of what actually happened in
Israel or when you see some of the riots
that are happening across Europe right
now and the and the calls for genocide
and everything else those are things
that obviously would have been censored
more and are being censored more on the
other platforms like YouTube like
Facebook etc etc so the fact that Elon
Musk the number one guy really in the
world right now defending all of our
ability to communicate freely over these
pipes over these magical wires uh that
he is going there uh I think sends a
real signal to people it also sends a
signal to the people who think that
either you know the sort of crazy people
who who's brains have been broken by Tik
Tock and everything else who thinks who
think that Israel made all of this up or
there's no evidence of it or anything
else so anyway Douglas Murray talking
about hey we are not going to tolerate
this Elon Musk going to the Ground Zero
of what is happening in the world right
now to see reality it is just the
beginning of something actually turning
we'll get to that in just a second let
me talk to you guys about truly office
uh you know this might sound
unbelievable but the quickest way to
secure your personal data is to ditch
mainstream office software providers
like Microsoft and Google who misuse
your data without your permission and
switch to a safeer alternative like
truly office software once you switch
you'll never look back because truly
office software gives you peace of mind
and control over your personal data
truly office software is secure private
alternative to mainstream office
software it doesn't track or sell your
data giving you complete control over
your personal information and getting
started is a breeze right now they're
offering a free trial of truly office
software just for our viewers and
listeners so that you can try it before
you buy it just go to truly
office.com Rumble to start your journey
towards data privacy and security before
you commit to another office software
that invades your privacy consider truly
office software it's the secure private
alternative you've been looking for go
to truly office.com Rumble rightow and
try it for free this offer is limited so
don't miss out and now back to me okay
so what else is happening in the world
right now right we all know what's
happening in England we all know what's
happening in Israel well now something
is really starting to burn hot in
Ireland and Ireland is not a country
that we talk about that often from an
American perspective so first I want to
read to you a tweet from a few days ago
this is Irish Prime Minister Leo vardar
and this is really really wild check
this out he wrote this is a day of
enormous joy and relief for Emily hand
and her family an innocent child who was
lost has now been found and returned and
we breathe a sigh of a massive sigh of
relief our prayers have been answered
now you might say well what is he
talking about there and why is that so
bizarre well I want to read to you the
community note that was put beneath it
uh readers added context that they
thought people might want to know the
terms lost and found are misleading
88-year-old Emily was lost when she was
kidnapped from a kabut by Hamas
terrorists she was found 50 days later
when she was exchanged by Hamas for
three Palestinian prisoners so as you
can probably figure out this this young
girl this 8-year-old girl who has now
been rescued not found uh she was in
Israel she had dual citizenship Irish
and Israeli citizenship and it's a
little Biz excuse me it's a little bizar
that the prime minister of Ireland in
saying instead of saying the obvious the
obvious truth that she was kidnapped in
a horrific terrorist attack and then
rescued uh you know rescued in a hostage
exchange um lost and found now Ireland
has been one of the worst countries when
it comes to the UN and voting against
Israel on all of these things things uh
that might be connected to some of this
but interestingly and now let's get to
Connor McGregor Conor McGregor who is a
you know basically MMA Superstar uh he
saw that as a whole bunch of other
people did once it got community noted
and he wrote this she was abducted and
of course he's Irish she was abducted by
an evil terrorist organization what is
with you and your government and you're
paid for media Affiliates constantly
downplaying SL attempting to repress
horrific acts that happened to Children
you are a disgrace the day after a
stabbing of children in Ireland not one
paper had it on their front cover we
will not forget now what of course
Connor is referencing you might not have
seen this if you were trying to get off
the machines over the weekend uh but an
Algerian stabbed several children in
Ireland uh they're trying to find out a
little bit more info on that at the
moment but then average Irish people not
racist people people who are sick of
their country being overrun and their
borders uh not uh being protected
started getting upset as one might when
children are uh stabbed or you know if
it's happening in Israel burned alive
etc etc we've got a headline here from
NBC News riots erupt in Dublin after
young children are stabbed police blamed
farri agitators for starting the
violence after a small group of
anti-immigrant protesters arrived at the
scene of the stabbing attack and clashed
with police so okay you guys get it this
is rinse and repeat how does the media
operate so uh an immigrant this guy from
Algeria stabs these children then a few
people show up to the place where it
happened and of course they're now far
right because they're defending the
children of their country and they are
the ones who got into the clash with the
police you guys get it now I want to
read you another tweet this is from John
Kavanaugh he's an MMA coach I think he
was he was Conor's coach right for many
years he wrote so what should happen
with this demented scumbag who attacked
women and kids today few years in jail
at our expense to get out and repeat
needs to be deported immediately and
never allow back or just hang him
there's no fixing him Conor McGregor
retweeted it and he wrote torture and
death so you can see there is something
escalating right now I think people in
light of what happened in Israel are
suddenly looking at their borders
looking at their country seeing people
call for genocide having algerians stab
their children and a whole bunch of
people are going I think we have had
enough yes we are tolerant yes we are
liberal yes we love diversity and all of
those things but finally people are
questioning woke politics and they are
getting over this nonsense I want to
read you another tweet from Conor
McGregor because he's really he's the
guy beat he's been pretty redpilled for
a while but it's like it seems like it's
happening in real time right now he
wrote us allows nonresidents to vote
visitors can vote I can fly in now and
register a vote in the United State
States elections surely not however
Ireland's current government is
proposing this a disgrace a shame hang
their heads in shame hashtag for Ashling
hashtag for Ireland he then tweeted out
this Ireland we are at War now another
one I mean the guy was really on it and
and I I like when decent people who are
not particularly political start getting
involved right this is how you actually
bring culture back Conor McGregor is
loved by literally millions of people
across the globe even if you're not an
an MMA person it's not it's not really
my thing but he is loved and respected
by millions of people because of his
talent in that ring right and then
sometimes push comes to shove and you
better stand up for things outside of
that ring out side of your area of
expertise or anything else so here's
another tweet by him he's referencing
Michael Martin who's a Minister of
Foreign Affairs in Ireland he wrote what
are we doing SL what have we done to
ensure this situation doesn't happen
again Michael since the heinous and
horrific murder of an Irish citizen in
broad daylight at the hands of a foreign
criminal there has been zero action
response from the three parties in power
nothing at all has been done yet what is
the holdup you have answered nothing
here we need a brand new task force
founded in Ireland with the sole
objective of assessing and monitoring
all entrance that come into Ireland and
we need to we need a clean sweep of
those already here under false pretenses
or that have broke the law here our
country is at stake and we will tolerate
nothing less ret travel around Europe is
not worth it to carry on with this
current system it is a failed system
announce this and correct it now correct
this or we are all finished the straw
has broken in the camels back your clock
is ticking and let's keep going with
Connor McGregor because he he was really
blowing up the Twitter he wrote isn't
that something oh so what he's
referencing here the guy that you're
going to see let me read the Tweet below
first liberal Irish journalist who
smears opponents of mass immigration as
far right uh gets sent on his bike by
locals after showing up to the site of
the stabbing so the guy that you're
seeing there he's just like this local
Lefty kind of woke journalist who's been
always going after the quote quote far
right so now Connor was commenting on
that he wrote isn't that something the
absolute picture of weak and feeble the
most divisive of all is the weak man one
of the most horrific crimes this nation
has ever seen has occurred we do not
care anymore what you sad cases have got
to say in a war you are nothing we are
not backing down we are only warming up
there will be no backing down until Real
Change is implemented for the safety of
our nation we are not losing any more of
our women and children to sick and
twisted people people who should not
even be in Ireland in the first place
call it what you want we do not care may
God help us all Ireland for victory
let's keep going with Connor McGregor on
Twitter deplorable we stand with Irish
businesses and of course what he's
referencing right down below is as you
know what does the left do what do the
wers do what do the uh illegal
immigrants do and all their antifa
comrades whenever anything happens
especially as it relates to race they
figure this is a good time to break into
Foot Locker and to other stores and
steal a whole bunch of stuff in the name
of Tolerance and diversity or something
like that uh and then as all this is
happening remember an Algerian a
non-irish Algerian and it's questionable
how he got into the country in the first
place he stabs these kids that's what
starts this whole thing then the media
starts going after the far right who
were the actual Irish people in Ireland
uh and what of course led to all of this
is they are part of the European Union
the borders have been open and
everybody's just wandering in here is
video of an anti-open border protest in
[Music]
Dublin do those seem like bad people do
those seem like far-right lunatics do
you think they're all just a bunch of
racists or do you think that maybe
they're Irish people who like Ireland
right so now let's go back to where we
started at the top of the show today
what was Douglas Murray talking about is
Douglas Murray a racist when he talks
about you know say the UK being for
British citizens and people that share
their culture and their beliefs and that
you can't import a whole bunch of people
who would gladly burn down the whole
damn thing and it doesn't make you far
right or racist or a bigot or a Nazi or
a transphobe if you push these people
out right if you don't stand for
something you will fall for anything so
of course that's him talking about it in
London there's Elon in Israel well
they're going uh we've just had about
enough with these people who break our
borders and come in and rape our women
and kill our children and all of those
things and now it's happening in Ireland
as well a little more detail on what's
actually happening in Ireland from the
daily wire former UFC champion an
Ireland native Connor McGregor is
reportedly now under investigation for
online hate speech linked to comments
made on social media criticizing Irish
authorities for their handling of a
suspected Algerian immigrants stabbing
five people including three children
last week McGregor's comments instantly
made the mixed martial artist a leading
voice in Ireland as the nation deals
with an influx of immigrants which
reportedly has risen to its second
highest level in recent months and among
the highest per capita in the European
Union authorities reportedly have since
launched an investigation into the mix
martial arts fighter as part of an
inquiry into the dissemination of
so-called online hate speech according
to the Sun Day times the investigation
comes as Irish officials have reportedly
stated preparing sorry have reportedly
started preparing to pass radical
legislation concerning the public speech
law which historically has lacked a
consistent definition Irish Prime
Minister Leo vardar recently told local
media that the lawmakers should
immediately pass the legislation in the
next few weeks to Target individuals who
post messages and images that stir up
hatred and violence now again again if
you just go by what the what I just read
to you six seven tweets by Conor
McGregor was he being hateful was he
targeting any specific person or group
of people that are actually Irish people
or he was he saying hey Ireland is
supposed to be a country it's supposed
to have borders and rules and a culture
like every other Nation that's the point
of nation states and we can't have
people here committing crime you've
already committed a crime by coming in
illegally we can't have people say
stabbing our kids that a bit much uh and
now of course who's the bad guy well
it's apparently Conor McGregor and the
people that support him here is video of
Irish Prime Minister Leo vardar
announcing uh new laws against hatred in
addition to that I think it's now very
obvious to anyone who might have doubted
it um that our incitement hatred
legislation is just not up to date it's
not up to date for the social media age
uh and we need that legislation through
and we need it through within a matter
of weeks um because it's it's not just
the platforms who have a responsibility
here and they do uh there's also the
individuals uh who post messages and
images online uh that stir up hatred and
violence uh and we need to be able to
use laws to go after them individually
as well guys you really need understand
how twisted and perverse this is and I
know for those of you that have watched
this show for a while like we've seen
this so many times that's why I said
rinse and repeat before but instead of
outrage instead of the Irish Prime
Minister being angry and outraged at
himself and his cabinet and everyone
else who let these people in and led to
this Algerian stabbing Irish children
his response is now oh it's those Irish
people online with their memes and
images who are causing all of the hate
against what his implication is is that
the hate is against these illegal
immigrants not the hate against say you
know the kid that the Algerian guy
stabbed but it goes further because here
is Leo varar Irish Prime Minister uh
going even further he's very upset that
Ireland is too white which uh Conor as
the whitest guy in the room and with
some Irish blood it's generally thought
of as a white Nation pretty pretty
pretty pretty white which isn't a
problem go one thing I strongly agree
with the deputy on is the need to Target
set a Target to have a number of people
from ethnic minorities in areas of the
public service we have a Health Service
that's very diverse although less so as
you go up toward the senior positions uh
not so much in the guardi not so much in
the Defense Forces not so much in the
education sector as the deputy mentioned
not at all in the Civil Service which is
very white including the Department of
Equality for example uh and that
actually needs to change um so we need
to have I think a target for people who
come from ethnic minority backgrounds uh
but also uh dedicated recruitment
campaigns to encourage people because we
do need uh a generation of young people
growing up in Ireland who are people of
color to see black and brown and School
principles
judges King Carla perhaps in the future
um who knows uh visibility uh and
opportunity is really important does
anyone ever stop these people and say
why why like no one's saying that no
black people can live in Ireland no
one's saying that no brown people can
become School principles in Ireland or
anything else Ireland is
94% white that's not a problem Irish
people are white
it's okay they like beer and whiteness
it's fine this is so insane but you see
what this woke ideology does and it only
goes one way right it only goes one way
they're importing all these algerians
they're importing these syrians and all
these people who again will gladly
destroy all of the beauty and Ireland I
was only in Ireland for three days when
I toured with Jordan years ago I would
absolutely love to go back David's
family is part Irish we are we are we
have been planning to go back for quite
some time like it it's a beautiful
beautiful country do you think all of
the people that they're importing route
care about that beauty care about that
culture care about that history or any
of that stuff and why is it that there's
no public official in Algeria going you
know we're awfully black here could we
get a couple Irish people Conor we're
going to send you on a fact-f finding
Mission we're sending Conor to Algeria
that's it book the flight
uh it it's all insane you're not going
to believe this if you go to Japan you
you know what it's filled with Brock can
you do this one what's Japan filled with
black people Japanese people that's
right there are Japanese people in Japan
it's it's so absolutely insane but of
course what what this really about
really is about is governments putting
the boot on the head of good decent free
people so here's a bit more this is
Ireland's green party they've got a
green party too it's not just green for
the Irish uh this is green party Senator
O'Reilly he's very excited because it's
time to squash Freedom when you think
about it all law all legislation is
about the Restriction of Freedom that's
exactly what we're doing here is we are
restricting freedom but we're doing it
for the common good you will see
throughout our constitution yes you have
rights but they are restricted for the
common good everything needs to be
balanced and if your views on other
people's identities go to to make their
lives unsafe insecure and cause them
such deep discomfort that they cannot
live in peace then I believe that it is
our job as legislators to restrict those
freedoms for the common good allor right
first off you guys know I love making a
correction on the Fly I called her a
himym I mean from what I can tell it
looks like a chick but who the hell
knows these days she could have a wang I
don't know uh but it's very exciting
she's going to restrict freedom for the
common good lady lady have you seen the
hunger games might I uh have you
download uh say a prequel of Star Wars
what did Palpatine do when they gave him
emergency powers to protect Freedom
didn't work out well for the Jedi Google
Order 66 you guys get it you guys get it
but this is happening all over the world
there are these like blips of goodness
right and those are the things that we
have to focus on those are the things
that we have to amplify and replicate
and all that and then craziness from our
government officials so here's a blip of
goodness for you uh this is in London
over the weekend there was a March
against anti-Semitism and apparently
about 100,000 people showed up I think
we've got an image for you it was rather
extraordinary about 100,000 people and
there are British flags and there are
Israeli flags and notice let's look
around do you see anyone in a mask
anyone in a mask anyone for I'm trying
to look real close anyone calling for
genocide are there any genocide callers
there anyone burning down a monument
anyone maybe cursing Winston Churchill
or anyone else no it was just peaceful
people and they were singing songs and
they were talking about freedom and
things of that
nature how old school of them anyway I
now want to read to you a tweet from the
Metropolitan Police this occurred
yesterday during uh this rally check
this out officers working as part of the
policing and Security operation for the
March against anti-Semitism have
arrested a 40-year-old man on the Strand
he refused to comply with a d a
direction to disperse under Section 35
of antisocial Behavior crime and
policing act now you might think this is
odd because we've been showing you weeks
and weeks of people calling for genocide
people you know vandalizing monuments
screaming at people breaking windows in
Jewish stores and nobody seems to be
arrested this is not only in London it's
in New York City and elsewhere but who
could this 40-year-old man be this is
very bizarre well I've got a tweet here
from Ian miles Chang he said the London
Metropolitan Police have a pre-crime
mandate just the potential of something
to cause offense is enough for them to
act but only when that something happens
to be Tommy Robinson two-tiered policing
at its finest and now I'm going to show
you some video this is a Tommy Robinson
I'll tell you a bit more about him in
just a moment uh being arrested at the
March against anti-Semitism now he's
he's a white guy he's British uh he has
been a defender of the Jewish people
even though people call him allright and
right right bring maniac and all that I
interviewed him he was one of the first
guys I interviewed on the Ruben report
back in I think 2015 if I'm not mistaken
here he is being uh even though he is a
supporter of Israel and the Jews in
London doing nothing uh illegal they
arrested him while he was having
breakfast they literally came up to the
restaurant he was waiting for his
breakfast to be uh delivered to the
table uh here they are arresting him at
the
rally
okay to be clear he did not do anything
he showed up at that rally to peacefully
uh you could say celebrate with those
people to talk about freedom and a
defense of not only Israel but obviously
of the UK and London specifically and
everything else they so I like what Ian
wrote there that this is pre- crime did
you guys see Minority Report like we're
starting to enter pre-crime that what
was the line there that they said can
you go back on the on the prompter for
just a second what was the specific line
in uh that they arrested him for um
under Section 35 there it is section 35
of the antisocial Behavior crime and
policing act antisocial Behavior I mean
that literally he was there having
breakfast to to protest peacefully with
those people now how about we do a
little compare and contrast could we do
that let's juxtapose some stuff here's a
video I think we showed you this one we
have so many of them uh here's a bunch
of people screaming crazy lunacy on the
Streets of London just over the past
couple
weeks it was terrifying the boys had to
be rescued by the police as bottles and
eggs rain down on
[Applause]
[Music]
them Muhammad hijab then threatened a
police officer that he'd kill the boy's
dog if he saw again however when the
when those zist came in with their dogs
that was an that was an act of
provocation so what we're saying now and
I'm making it very clear so everyone
understands if those dogs come close to
us again we will see it as an act of
aggression and we will kill those dogs
we'll put them
down I think we all know who the good
guys and bad guys are here there's a
slim layer of people who are confused
about some of this stuff and then
there's a layer who use the people who
are confused for all of the wrong
reasons uh but of course nobody has been
arrested at any of these things the guy
threatening to kill the dog the people
calling for genocide they're throwing
eggs at the cops they're breaking
windows they're vandalizing monuments
nobody gets arrested there then one
British citizen shows up to have
breakfast at the March against
anti-Semitism and he's the bad guy well
where else is this happening we've been
through London we were in Israel earlier
with Elon Musk we've been to Ireland
bunch of weirdness happening all all
over the place well guess what guys of
course it's also happening here in
America uh here is a pro they call it a
pro Palestine rally but it's a pramas
rally as protesters illegally occupied
the Manhattan Bridge in New York this is
just
[Applause]
yesterday first off I want to make just
like a little clerical point on the idea
of free speech when when you see the
March against anti-Semitism in London uh
they got permits to do that right so the
police come in they set up other ways
for people to drive and things of that
nature they weren't stopping anyone from
getting anywhere we we can have an and I
think it's worth having an interesting
discussion how will Western Civilization
survive just like having protests and
counter protests all the time but if you
go through the proper channels to have
your protest and do it and do it
peacefully then then that is you
exercising your fre Free Speech right
especially on on public property uh as
opposed to going to someone's house and
doing it then then then there's a
private property issue uh what these
people were doing at the Manhattan
Bridge they just decided to take over
the Manhattan Bridge they didn't care
whether there were ambulances that had
to get through or if people had to get
work to work or somebody had to get to a
babysitting job or whatever it might be
they also chant the usual nonsense about
genocide there is no genocide in Gaza
for as many people that have been killed
in Gaza the the Palestinian population
we've been through through this a
million times already has basically 5x
since 1948 right it was about a million
people now it's about 5 million people
something like that there is a war they
are still firing Rockets into Israel
there's a war and people do die in war
and generally in a war you want to kill
more of the people that are trying to
kill you than the amount of you that
will uh be killed by them that's
generally how war is going on anyway all
of this is happening to the backdrop of
us realizing that we have a problem at
our border so now check this out this is
video just from this weekend at our
Southern border take a
look Arizona so that's Arizona now
interestingly Connor my director who I
mentioned earlier very very white no
offense um he celebrated he's from
Arizona and celebrated Thanksgiving in
Arizona now you're I assume all of your
family or most of your family is white
pretty much white did you invite any of
those people they know they were mostly
black and brown so you invited none of
they're walking into your state you
invite none of them into the home to
share the the potatoes the stuffing the
T maybe he is racist we'll find out when
we s him to Algeria okay so that's
happening that's what's happening in
Arizona right now and do you think it's
possible and it's not because of their
skin color but it's because of the ideas
that are in their brain the wrong ideas
do you think it's possible that some of
those people may not love everybody in
Arizona that if Connor's family was to
invite them over for Thanksgiving your
mom's gonna hate me after this show
she's a big fan love you love you um if
she invited them over for Thanksgiving
you think it's possible they they might
not be thrilled with all the freedoms of
America or they might be looking around
going look at all these white people oh
I want that
thing but we're letting it happen we are
letting it happen the enemy is here and
we are letting it happen but people
people in Ireland are realizing it
people in London are realizing it people
in America are realizing it people in
Argentina are realizing it people in
Spain are realizing it so again
something is starting to turn here but
every you know this every time we start
getting some winds every time people
start waking up every time it feels like
oh we're grasping something and we're
going to be able to do something a
little different this time what happens
well the government or the powers that
be they come in with more stupidity so
here is ariti prabhakar I think I got
her name right uh she is is the what
what is she she is the Joe Biden's uh
adviser on science and technology and
she has a uh very robust you'll see a
very robust defense because Joe Biden
who's 80 some odd years old who has
dementia who can't string two sentences
together apparently he's also signing
executive orders as to what we're going
to do with AI so a man who has very
little eye in his own brain intelligence
you got it uh is now signing executive
ERS that we're going to be able to stop
the supercomputers uh from taking I
somehow doubt it but anyway you'll see
how we're connecting this thing because
of course yes Equity civil rights blah
blah blah go hi I'm Ary pacher I'm the
President's chief adviser on Science and
Technology artificial intelligence is
one of the most consequential
Technologies of our time and President
Biden's been clear we have to manage
ai's risks so that we can seize its
benefits this technology is moving fast
and so is the Biden Harris
Administration the president just issued
a broad broad executive order on AI and
it starts by tackling ai's risks it sets
up a framework so that you can know how
safe an AI model is it kicks off work to
identify AI generated content so that
you know when you're interacting with AI
and it has a whole host of Provisions
that will protect equity and civil
rights and privacy and democracy we're
doing all of this to mitigate risks so
that we can put AI to work to meet our
great aspirations
as a country AI is helping us to fight
climate change to improve health
outcomes and to bolster security and
safety around the
world AI is helping us fight climate
change oh
sorry haven't been in studio in a
couple days um look look AI there is a
lot of stuff to talk about with AI we
will do more shows on ai ai basically is
the computer's becoming sentient right
like this is what every science fiction
movie is about right from from the movie
AI right remember the movie AI or from
iRobot you could look at virtually every
sci-fi any Philip K dick book um the
idea that the machines Terminator the
machines will no longer need a SK need a
Skynet will turn on right that's what
happens in Terminator and it realizes
the humans are now the enemy that's also
what happened in iroot uh Will Smith
movie is not great but the book was
pretty good Isaac azov um there are
things to talk about related to what how
do we deal with this uncanny valley that
we are entering right now that perhaps
we're in and how do we manage some of
this stuff and maybe the robots will not
need us anymore try the Matrix right all
all of the stuff you guys get all that
but if you think that these incompetent
bumbling buffoons led by a man with
dementia can put together a framework
that's going to make AI safer for
anybody and then on top of the fact even
if they could what did she say they're
going to do well they're going to handle
Equity so AI that means the robots the
machines the programs the algorithms are
somehow going to push Equity into our
society and of course what is equity
Equity is institutionalized racism whoa
whoa whoa we got a whole bunch of white
people doing good over there we better
take them down and make sure black
people are doing better that is known as
discrimination children you got it guys
you got it but somehow the AI is going
to take care of equity civil rights
climate change and a whole host of other
things but don't
worry don't worry guys because not only
are they going to do that but then we
have other great leaders like Governor
Kathy hokel up in New York and what she
focused on well much like the Irish
Prime Minister she's focused on what
you're saying because if you keep saying
those mean things then something bad
might
happen today I'm directing the director
of division of Homeland Security and
emergency services to
develop media literacy tools for K
through
12 in our Public Schools this will teach
students and even teachers to help
understand how to spot conspiracy
theories and misinformation
disinformation and online
hate start talking about what we're
seeing out there give the
teachers the tools they need to help
these conversations in
school and by teaching younger New
Yorkers about how to discern between
digital fact and digital fiction we can
better inoculate them
from hatred and the spread of it and
help prepare them for a very fast moving
and often confusing world I want to be
clear lady I hate you and there's no
inoculation for that she's going to
inoculate young people from hatred that
that sounds doable yeah yeah yeah maybe
like a shot maybe like big Pharma could
come up with some sort of thing that
they occasionally jab you with and then
you know who knows what else it's going
to do to you next thing you know you got
it all right so what is what what is she
doing though of course they're going to
stop conspiracy theories they're going
to stop misinformation and
disinformation these are the very same
people who told you that social
distancing made sense who told you that
being locked down in your house made
sense who told you the Jabs work who
told you that Donald Trump was a Russian
plant who told you that Brett Kavanaugh
was a serial rapist who told you that
the Covington kids were racist who told
you that Jesse smette was was going to
be lynched all they've lied about
everything and now they have Ai and the
tools and the framework to keep you safe
from other such things that they've lied
about it's really rather extraordinary
uh but as you guys know I like to end
the show on a positive note we've got a
couple more clips for you uh and as I've
tried to do today there's bad stuff
happening and there's good people
stepping up against it right there are
people realizing whether it's Douglas
Murray who's been warning about this
stuff for years in the UK he wrote a
book I highly recommend you watch it or
at Le or that you read it or at least
watch my interview with Douglas from
about 7 years ago probably he wrote a
book called The Strange death of Europe
it's a spectacular book that predicted
all of this some people have a pretty
good track record when it comes to all
this so whether it's Douglas Murray in
the UK or it's Elon seeing what's going
on in Israel or it's Connor McGregor you
know fighting for an Ireland that he
loves that that most Irish people love
whether it's any of those things or the
the people that whether it's Tommy
Robinson fighting for a London that he
loves um well now we need some other
people to step up and some and we need a
political class that will step up and
guess what there are places on Earth
where that is happening so now I want to
go to Hungary and as you remember we
were in Hungary about six months ago uh
and I got to meet Victor Orban we it was
not on camera but we spent about a half
hour together and now I'm going to do my
Victor Orban impression which mostly
sounds like Dracula but Victor Orban we
stood on the uh The Edge we were at the
palace over there and we're standing it
was a beautiful day and we're on the
danoob and and he said look I like
hungry I just like hungry people I want
to keep the country for Hungary that's
my Victor orad okay and that's it he I
don't it has nothing to do with black
people I'm edit editorializing now but
like he just likes Hungary and he wants
borders for Hungary and he wants
hungarians to flourish and that seems to
be what's happening there so here is
Victor Orban talking about why he cares
about hungry and what he's going to do
about uh keeping it
hungry
for
[Applause]
don't think my impersonation of him is
so bad now that was a completely
different one but the point is you get
it does he seem like a dick does he seem
like a racist and someone that hates
anybody or does he seem like someone
that just cares about his country hey we
have borders we have problems here we
want to make sure our social services
aren in strain that our economy is in
strained uh we have demographic issues
and what we want to do is create
policies as a government that will
encourage people to have families and
more kids and build more structures
bottom up so we can build a thriving
Society like that's so obviously true
it's ridiculous and isn't it also
interesting when you hear someone and I
I talk about this all the time right
like when you hear someone telling the
truth they don't have to scream about
everything their arms aren't waving
they're not doing the AOC or the Rashida
Talib or the Hitler right it's a lot of
genu flecting and screaming or whatever
he's just calmly saying he hey it's
hungry I like hungry you like hungry
we're going to remain hungry how about
that uh and guys this wave now this
thing that's happening or all of the bad
news that's out there and there is bad
news this Freedom wave is now happening
in Argentina right we saw the election
last week it's happening in Spain they
are having massive anti-socialist
protests hundreds of thousands of people
we showed you clips of that last week as
well it's now happening in Ireland right
it's happening in Israel the left has
been basically annihilated in Israel
they the left which for years said we
want peace with these people and they
said we're here to kill all of you and
they said we'd like to have peace with
you well now even they are waking up
it's happening in America right and it's
a little trickier here in America
because we have this pres presidential
election coming and we'll have to figure
out what goes on there but like there
are good people waking up here there are
good people waking up in Hungary there
are good people waking up in France even
in Canada and guess what now another
country that had elections last week the
Netherlands so the Netherlands just
elected uh girl Gert Wilders uh he he
got 35 seats in the parliament which
means he will create the next government
so he will be the next prime minister he
has been this guy's been you've probably
seen videos of him for the last probably
two decades he has been one of the most
anti-immigrant
anti-radical Islam politicians in the
well in all of Europe but certainly uh
in amps in Holland uh and he is now
going to be the next prime minister of
the Netherlands take a
look with his aggressive
anti-immigration and anti-islam rhetoric
Hal ters is set to shake up Dutch
Politics the veteran Firebrand placed
anti-islam policies at the core of his
Party pvv founded in
2004 Wilders has since vowed to stop a
quote Islamic Invasion has held
competitions for cartoons of the Prophet
Muhammad and has been convicted for
insulting
Moroccans Brussels wants to inundate us
with third world immigrants mostly from
Islamic countries it wants to distribute
these immigrants all over the European
Union and that my friends will be a
disaster a ban on mosques Islamic
schools krans and headscarfs from
government buildings are among the
proposals on his PV TV Manifesto but he
sought to tone down his anti-islamic
rhetoric in the runup to the election
immigration was a key theme of The
Campaign after the previous government
collapsed in a disagreement over Asylum
rules with Wilders taking a Hardline
stance the pvv has pledged to deport
illegal immigrants and proposes a freeze
on
Asylum and the
hope the hope is that people get their
country back that we make sure that the
Netherlands is for the Dutch again that
we will limit the Asylum tsunami and
migration a self-proclaimed fan of
hungary's Victor Oban wers is a staunch
euroskeptic and wants to hold a binding
referendum to leave the EU he has called
for the Netherlands to significantly
reduce its payments to Brussels and to
block the entrance of any new members
unlike many other European leaders
Wilders wants to stop arming Ukraine
saying the Netherlands needs the weapons
to defend
itself you know it's funny before I get
to any of the substantive stuff doesn't
he look like if Matt Gates and Donald
Trump had a baby it would be that guy
like the hair the body the whole thing
anyway look do you think he just became
prime minister because he's racist
because ultimately the people of the
Netherlands are racist or is it because
they have also been overrun and they are
dealing with the same stuff that you're
seeing out of London and New York City
and Paris and elsewhere and they want
borders and that the European Union has
been an abject failure and that they
have had enough with people coming into
their country who don't care about their
country or would gladly upend their
country and they would like their
country back how crazy would that be if
the Netherlands was for the Dutch by the
way the Netherlands the Dutch same
people it's all the same Holland the
Netherlands the Dutch I know it's
confusing for people all the same people
it's as simple as that guys it really is
as simple as that and of course he will
be called far right and Tommy Robinson
will be called far right and Douglas
Murray will be called far right and
Conor McGregor will be called far right
and I'll be called far right and you'll
be called far right and if we are all
far right then I suspect that the center
is now the right and that is the thing
that probably will save the west and if
it doesn't work then do you know what
will be what will happen on the other
side as our societies really start to
crumble as sectarian violence really
starts to break out in all of the West
and everything else then some really bad
people will become the leaders of these
countries and then some really bad
things will happen and you know what'll
happen then good people ordinary men
will start doing some really bad things
so now one more for you uh this is
Jordan Peterson on how Ordinary Decent
Germans became genocidal
Nazis many many many many of the people
not all many of the people who were
involved in the Nazi atrocities were
perfect L Ordinary People they were just
like you and you think no I wouldn't do
that it's like that's not what the
evidence
suggests the evidence suggests that the
vast majority of people in Nazi Germany
went along with it now not all of them
were dragged into the abyss itself but
plenty were and if you think you
wouldn't have been one of them that just
means it's highly likely that you would
have cuz you have no idea what you're
capable of there's a great book about
that it's terrifying book called
Ordinary men and it's about the
initiation of a police Battalion from
Germany who went to Poland after the
Germans marched into Poland now these
were ordinary men they were policemen
middle-aged who had grown up before the
Nazi propaganda Mill got going okay so
they weren't indoctrinated Nazis from
like the time they were four they're
just ordinary middle class guys plus
their Commander told them in Poland when
they were starting to do milit AR work
even though they were civilian policemen
that they could go home that they didn't
have to do this job and that there would
be no repercussions and in fact out of
the Battalion a number of men right at
the beginning said I'm not doing this
and they went home Mo the vast majority
went along now the guys that left
thought I don't care I'm not doing this
but most people didn't and part of the
reason they didn't do it is because they
were loyal to their to their peers by
the end of this which took months these
guys were taking
n naked pregnant women out into the
middle of fields and shooting them in
the back of the
head get the point I think you get the
point right if all of the people who
right now are trying to stand up for
their Nations let the Netherlands be for
the Dutch let Ireland be for the Irish
let America be for Americans and by the
way that's a little more complex because
we are a Melting Pot but we do have a
culture worth defending and we have laws
worth defending and a founding worth
defending and all of those things if we
will not allow those things to happen
What will come on the other side are
much worse people who will do
unspeakable things then good people that
we all know will also do unspeakable
things for the very reasons that Jordan
just laid out right I I've mentioned it
a couple times over the years that when
Jordan and I used to tour he would ask
often we did you know hundred some odd
shows and I'd say he did it probably 30
40 times how many of you here in front
of five 6 thousand people how many of
you here would have been a Nazi and of
course nobody applauds nobody raises
their hand
and as he just laid out in that clip
that means he probably would have been
because these people were not all in
completely indoctrinated four-year-olds
that s you know that that grew up with
all the wrong ideas and then said okay
let's kill all these people right but
then one day they're shooting pregnant
women out in the field it's because over
time if you are pushed far enough and
then the wrong ideas come in and then
Society starts turning and no one else
is good around and then you don't want
to be on the wrong side of being shot
too humans can do hard horrible things
to each other so I think the West has
has a kind of interesting moment right
now we can choose which way we want to
go I think you know which way I want to
go which way do you want to go well
we'll discuss this more in our postgame
show at Ruben report. locals.com in
about 30 seconds uh reminder we did
create a second account on Twitter if
you are on the Twitter it's Ruben report
show that's where all the clips of the
show are going to go up oh and uh over
well it wasn't over the weekend we aired
it yesterday but a few days ago uh right
before Thanksgiving I interviewed
former US ambassador to Israel David
fredman who I also interviewed when we
were in Israel about six or seven months
ago uh who is just he's we've become
good friends he's just an absolutely
wonderful decent human being uh he was
here in Florida for a couple days
helping out with some with some Outreach
for Israel and then he's going back I
think he might even be back there now um
and uh and we sat down right in here and
we chatted for about an hour it was
really it was really something and I
have to say the the uh the contrast of
you know 6 months ago being in Israel in
Jerusalem with him talking about how
peaceful it was versus then having him
here in Florida in my home in light of
what has happened was was a bit jarring
but it's really wonderful uh you can
check that out it's up on Rumble and
YouTube and locals and everywhere else
uh it is me Monday do we have the meme
for today we have my meme for today Bay
Area car owners have been deliberately
leaving their trunks open in an effort
to avoid forced entry by thieves they're
really building a utopian society over
there of course that's Mr Jerry Seinfeld
uh if you want to join us for me Monday
Ruben report. locals.com postgame show
in just a second oh and we leave you
with Connor McGregor he was the he was
the man of the hour on this fine show we
wish Phoenix a happy birthday and we
will see you later by I just want to say
From The Bottom Of Me heart I'd like to
take this chance to
apologize to absolutely nobody the
double champ does what the he
wants
[Music]